our society you know has always hailed
teachers as
heroes selfless noble courageous
educators and caretakers of our children
the teaching profession was one of the
few we were supposed to celebrate
unquestioningly
teachers were one of only a few
professional groups we were meant to
applaud simply for
existing now this attitude towards
towards really any profession at all
was and is and has always been
wrong-headed nobody is a hero
merely for working in a certain
occupation i don't care what the
occupation is
because they're getting paid whatever
the line of work is most people get into
it because it's something they think
they can do
and they want to do and they think they
can make money doing it it's not a bad
reason to take on a job by any means
it's also not heroic it's sort of a
morally neutral motivation most of the
time
doing something because you want to do
it and you think you're good at it
doesn't make you a martyr or a saint it
doesn't make you a bad person either
just makes you a person like the rest of
us so there are there are good teachers
plenty of them
even heroic teachers i've known some but
they aren't good or heroic simply for
being teachers
and that's the distinction to keep in
mind the problem with adopting a
romanticized view of any or
any any profession is that it makes it
impossible to hold the people
in that profession accountable or to
criticize them when they deserve it
this is exactly why this romanticized
idea was cultivated in the
first place it becomes especially
problematic when we're talking about
people who work so closely with and have
such an influence over our children
you know this should be cause for extra
scrutiny more accountability
louder criticism when warranted because
the consequence of turning a blind eye
or ignoring
the bad things when your children aren't
concerned could be catastrophic
the teachers unions have made this
situation so much worth but worse
both by framing any criticism of
teachers as an attack on the teaching
profession
haranguing the public into turning that
blind eye and ignoring the neglect or
abuse of our children in the school
system
which does happen and has always
happened and also by fiercely protecting
the bad teachers
while demanding ever more considerations
and benefits and perks
for all teachers irrespective of their
job performance
the whole situation is quite a mess to
put it mildly and that mess has been
thrown into much sharper relief over the
past
nearly what a year now when schools
across the country have been shut down
it was of course known almost from the
beginning as we've talked about many
times in the show
that there was no real reason to have
schools shut down at all
as children are not likely to contract
or spread the virus
it became even clearer as time went on
that the consequences of having the
school shut down
and trying to replace them with skype
and zoom sessions
were dire we talked yesterday about the
child suicide epidemic and one of the
largest school districts in the country
prompting a renewed push for classes to
resume
in person in that district and yet still
the teachers unions and many teachers
themselves though certainly not all
have demanded that schools stay shut
education be damned the children be
damned
goal posts keep moving and there's no
end to this process of goal post
shifting as we have learned
here's how bad it's gotten the
washington post has an editorial
um an appropriately critical even fiery
editorial
about the teachers union in fairfax
county and um
everything that teachers union is doing
to avoid going back to work
let me read a bit this is written by
rory cooper who's a parent to three
students in the district
it says quote the fairfax county school
system demanded and then received high
priority placement for teachers and
administrators to be vaccinated against
the coronavirus
those vaccines began a week ago and
according to the fairfax county public
schools superintendent scott brabrand
yes his name is bra brand anyway 5
000 teachers have received their first
dose and an additional 22 000 teachers
are registered to receive their first
dose soon
and yet having jumped to the front of
the vaccine line
bra brand the fcps school board and the
uh i can't even say the last name
without laughing that's
you know i should be in public school
myself um the f's and the fc
fcps school board and the teachers unit
are delaying opening schools
that raises the question of why they
have the priority placement to be
to begin with and whether these
vaccinations should be immediately
halted so that high-risk individuals or
public servants who have been working
outside of their homes for the entirety
of the year have access
okay so let's not um understate what's
happened here
the teachers union engaged in a form of
extortion really holding the education
system hostage
so that they themselves could get to the
front
of the vaccine line butting in front of
the elderly people
sick people other high-risk people keep
in mind that
the average age of a teacher in the u.s
is 42
about 15 percent of teachers are under
30
under 30. so these by and large are
not high-risk people many of them have
little to worry about even if they get
sick if you're 27
even if you're a teacher and you get
sick you're probably gonna be
so the statistics tell us yet they were
put to the front of the line
and after being given what they want
they still refuse to go to work
and when i say they i mean the union we
have to keep in mind again that there
are plenty of individual teachers who
oppose this and vocally so
though not enough for being vocal to my
mind but it gets worse listen to this
at the january 21st school board meeting
fairfax education association president
kimberly adams said she received her
first vaccine dose on january 14th two
days ahead of the scheduled start
for school personnel she has said that
her union would not support a return to
full-time education even in the fall
the fall as in september 2021
nine months after she was vaccinated the
union says that all students
must also be vaccinated adams also wants
14 days of zero community spread
yes she now wants the students to be
vaccinated too
but kids again are a very very low risk
group also and this seems like a
relevant problem
a little bit of a logistical issue here
there aren't any vaccines currently
available for kids under 10
or rather under 14 actually
and her demand for two weeks of zero
spread is a demand for schools to never
resume
ever and yet these people still want to
get paid
have been getting paid they're demanding
front of the line for the vaccine
full pay full benefits but without
having to do their job
for a year now and counting
this is quite simply one of the greatest
displays of cowardice and selfishness i
have ever witnessed
and if you think i'm exaggerating
remember again that children are not
learning anything
through zoom class listen to the
teachers themselves they'll tell you
so the kids their education is being
stunted and meanwhile they're
increasingly falling into depression and
suicide
the teachers unions look at this and
just shrug their shoulders
the only thing they care about the only
thing period
at all is that they personally get the
most amount of money
and the most amount of benefits for
doing the least amount of work possible
and that has always been the concern of
the teachers union always
and don't expect anybody in the current
administration to speak up forcefully
against this
the the chicago's teachers union is also
refusing to return to work even though a
plan was put in place to open schools
again
so the city wants to open the schools
but the teachers union is saying we're
not going to go they're stamping their
feed
and saying they're not going to go back
to the schools because they're too
afraid
president biden was asked about this
yesterday and had a chance to stand up
for
you know the kids and for the education
system but instead
here was his answer right now the
chicago teachers union has
refused they defied an order to return
to in-person classing for in-person
classrooms
because of a lack of vaccinations
do you believe sir the teachers should
return to schools
now i believe we should make
school classrooms safe and secure
for the students for the teachers
and for the the help that's in those
schools
maintaining the facilities we need new
ventilation systems in those schools
we need testing for people coming in and
out of the classes we need testing for
teachers as well as students
and we need the capacity the capacity to
know
that in fact the sa the sick of the
circumstance in the school
is safe and secure for everyone for
example
there's no reason why the clear
guidance will be that every school
should be
thoroughly sanitized from the from the
laboratories
to the hallways and so this is about
making and none of the school districts
that i'm aware of there may be some
public school districts have insisted
that all those pieces be in place yep
there's his answer what what what talk
about cowardice that's the theme here
what an absolute coward he had a chance
to stand up
i mean democrats are terrified of
teachers unions we know that
he had a chance to stand up and say
listen get back to work the kids need
you
stop whining and get back to work
instead he talks about new ventilation
new ventilation systems
in all of the schools in the whole
country
why do they all even need it
what else do you want maybe we should
demolish all the schools and just
rebuild them from scratch
just to be safe yeah there could be some
leftover viruses in there or
you know you never know there could be a
virus hiding somewhere under a floor
tile so let's just let's just
demolish them all or better yet demolish
them all and not rebuild them because
you know we might as well if they aren't
being used
the upshot here is that school will not
return this year
for millions of kids and probably not in
the fall either
when all is said and done millions of
kids might end up missing
two years of their education
missing one year is now the best case
scenario
think about that now for any kid whose
parents
took over and homeschooled they won't
have missed anything in fact they're
gonna be better off
but most parents aren't doing that
um there are many parents who who can't
do it because they still have to work
uh and so those kids millions of them
are simply going without and that will
now continue indefinitely
because of the the the chronic
unadulterated
cowardice self-interest callousness and
laziness
of the teachers unions and many of its
members
it's as simple as that listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated